[Musique]
en hiver la réserve de ta aulas est
plongé dans un décor de fin du monde un
monde protégé des fureurs du pacifique
par une mince bande de galets où
viennent s'échouer des centaines de
troncs d'arbres emporté par l'érosion et
les tempêtes
[Musique]
il y à bien des années des indiens se
sont installés ici au bord de la rivière
queen hôte qui a donné son nom à la
tribu
ouais
les queens autres vivent encore des
quelques hectares de forêt qu'on leur a
laissé mais aussi de la pêche au saumon
et de la récolte d'un gros coquillage
doré le rasoir
[Musique]
ce matin les conditions atmosphériques
sont particulièrement mauvaise il ya
défaut d'aller sur la plage pour
ramasser quelques rasoir pour son dîner
larry s'enfonce dans la rivière il pense
qu'il aura plus de chance en remontant
ses filets ici tout dépend de la météo
hier c'était vraiment pourri du coup la
récolte de rasoir n'était pas bonne j'ai
parlé avec l'un des gars certainement
l'un des meilleurs pêcheurs à pied de la
tribune
il me disait qu'il n'avait récolté que
14 clame hier alors que la semaine
d'avant il en avait ramassé 130 kilos
pendant que larry et bien à l'abri dans
un bras de la rivière
les autres membres de la tribu ont tous
choisi de braver les éléments
une soixantaine de voitures attendent un
signe et du policier tribales
car dans ce conte de l'amérique la pêche
à pied commence toujours par une course
folle sur la plage
[Musique]
les bande sableuse infinie de l'état de
washington font office de route le pied
à fond sur l'accélérateur
c'est à celui qui arrivera le premier
sur les portions de pêche les plus
prisés
[Musique]
shawn l'ami de larry est déjà au bord de
l'eau le géant est considéré par les
siens comme le plus rapide des pêcheurs
de rasoir
décors verriers est ce qu'on appelle une
seule journée ça remue pas mal
aujourd'hui
il ya bien des rasoirs mais c'est pas
terrible
voici ce que j'ai ramassé jusqu'ici
environ un kilo c'est difficile comme
boulot il ya des jours où se fait de
l'argent facilement
parfois je viens ici je récolte 150
kilos mais un jour comme aujourd'hui je
vais probablement faire 25 kg peut être
si je suis chanceux si je ne me fais pas
renversé par les vagues
regardez-la y en a c'est un gros le trou
est grand plus le razer ego en général
tu vas être un peu plus gros que la
moyenne
les communautés indiennes de la
péninsule d'olympic sont les seuls à
bénéficier d'un débouché commercial pour
les rasoirs lors des grandes marées le
nombre de pêcheurs varient selon le
cours du marché
aujourd'hui presque toute la tribu queen
hôte s'est donné rendez vous sur l'une
des plages de la réserve
prix de chaque coquillages 1 dollar 50
une bonne occasion pour la plupart de se
faire un peu d'argent rapidement et
boucler les fins de mois difficiles
après trois heures de pêche effréné tout
s'arrête quoi qu'il arrive la police
tribale veille
pas question de dépasser leurs limites
il en va de la survie des stocks de
coquillages et donc de la bonne santé de
l'économie du village indien
joe shoemaker a été mandatée par le
gouvernement fédéral pour aider les
indiens à mieux gérer leurs ressources
marines le biologiste n'est pas venu
s'installer sur cette côte
inhospitalière par hasard
toute cette côte de l'état de washington
c'est le meilleur endroit pour les
rasoirs
c'est la meilleure cote de tous les
états unis la raison c'est que endroit
là bas où la vague fn l'eau est
tellement bras c'est que ça génère de
lui si chaud et du coup il ya une
certaine espèce de plancton qui se
développe dans les vagues
ce plancton les ramener vers le rivage
et nourrit les rasoirs qui vivent ici
donc c'est un endroit idéal pour que les
clame se développe
la température est parfaite et la
nourriture ne manque à la nuit tombée
juste avant le retour de la marée
chaque clan chaque famille un des fils
pour la pesée
lors de cette pêche commerciale aucun
coquillages ne peut quitter la plage
sans avoir été vendus aux autorités
queen haute malgré la tempête
shawn aura lutté jusqu'au bout pour
quelques dollars de plus j'étais en
train de chasser ces maudites mouettes
qui on voulait mais rasoir
vous les bouffer mais coquillages j'ai
dû en perdre deux kilos environ
aujourd'hui c'est un combat mais bon
c'est mieux que rien du tout je serai là
demain le jour d'après le jour suivant
dès que je le pourrai
[Musique]
combien vous avez gagné aujourd'hui 3 ya
40 60 80 100 127 dollars 50
si vous devez prendre vos heures de
pêche peut pas se plaindre
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant trois jours la pêche au rasoir a
été plus connaître sur la plage de tao
là en dehors de la pêche commerciale
chaque indien a aussi le droit d'aller
récolter des rasoirs uniquement pour
nourrir sa famille aujourd'hui même
larry a délaissé ses filets à saumon
pour aller pêcher quelques coquillages
pour son dîner le rasoir fait partie des
mets traditionnels de la culture cui
notes fribourg yi ou en soupe les
familles du village la commode à toutes
les sauces entre l'autre calamars et la
coquille saint jacques
on dit que c'est une merveille pour le
palais
[Musique]
mais derrière ce goût si particulier et
au delà de l'intérêt très lucrative deux
sets face à pied se cache une vraie
menace pour la santé des familles
queen's il y a quinze ans des
biologistes ont découvert qu'une toxine
venue du large pouvait mettre en danger
la vie des amateurs de ce coquillage à
la chair blanche étendre la plage où
nous nous rendons maintenant et la plage
la plus au nord de la réserve a été
fermé récemment à cause de la présence
d'acide domoïque alors on va faire
d'autres prélèvements pour voir si le
niveau de toxines à baisser suffisamment
pour rouvrir la plage à la pêche
ça veut dire aussi que les gens qui
vivent là bas n'ont pas de plage pour
récolter des rasoirs en ce moment et
pour les ramener à la maison pour le
dîner alors oui ils sont fâchés et il
aimerait que les niveaux de toxines
baisse mais en attendant il va falloir
faire preuve de patience
après la fermeture de toutes ces plages
en 98 l'état de washington décide de
mobiliser ces scientifiques pour mieux
connaître l'impact de cet oxyde tueuse
porter par les courants marins
une fois par semaine jo effectué des
prélèvements d'eau de mer sur les plages
de la réserve
il ramasse aussi quelques coquillages
qui seront ensuite analysés en
laboratoire ces algues sont aussi de la
nourriture pour les rasoirs
ils se nourrissent de cette algue brune
qui vient du large le problème c'est
qu'ils ne font pas la différence entre
la mauvaise algues et qui génère l'acide
domoïque et la bonne algues
cette toxine va droit au cerveau et gris
peu à peu les neurones et en résumé
provoque des courts circuits dans votre
cerveau cela entraîne des réactions
convulsive éventuellement un coma mais
le plus gros problème c'est que ça
détruit certaines zones du cerveau
il semble qu en particulier la mémoire
sont affectés par cet oxyde ciel bande
d'idiots regardez-moi ça sont devenus
fous en 1987 au canada plus de 100
personnes tombent malades après avoir
ingéré des moulins toxiques et trois
d'entre elles décèdent d'autres pères de
la mémoire
le danger est donc bien réel mais ne
semble pas inquiéter une poignée
d'individus qui s'obstinent à récolter
les rasoirs alors que la pêche est
formellement interdite sur la plage de
cala locke & key ce qui se passe ici
salut mon pote je vais analyser ces
coquillages pour savoir s'ils sont
toxiques
on dit que ça peut être dangereux de
manger ces coquillages
mais non ça peut pas faire de mal aux
indiens ah bon pourquoi
ce qu'on vit au bord de l'eau
le lendemain matin les rasoirs que jo a
récolté sont arrivés dans la banlieue de
seattle situé à plus de trois heures de
route de la réserve
les coquillages sont analysés ici deux
fois par mois dans un laboratoire du
département de la santé à partir des
résultats obtenus les plages de la
façade pacifique seront ouvertes ou
fermées à la pêche
voici une photo prise au microscope
elle vous montre bien cette algue qui
génère l'acide domoïque les rasoirs se
nourrissent de sepang vous savez ce sont
des coquillages qui filtrent la
nourriture et lorsqu'il se nourrissent
de 7,1 et bien ils deviennent tout
simplement toxiques
c'est ça la fameuse zone et se donne un
chien dans l'état de washington
la pêche aux coquillages rapporterait
près de 100 millions de dollars chaque
année
les autorités ont donc tout intérêt à
protéger la population américaine de
toute intoxication la recherche brasse
beaucoup d'argent mais on s'interroge
encore sur les effets méconnu de cette
biotoxines il est une théorie qui dit
que les indiens mange beaucoup de
coquillages c'est une des base de leur
alimentation est que ce qu'ils
accumulent rey à chaque fois un peu de
toxines
je ne sais pas dans quelle proportion
mais la théorie veut que la mère
contaminerait le lait maternel est par
la suite son enfant va développer des
problèmes à cause de cet empoisonnement
c'est ce qui pourrait expliquer
aujourd'hui des taux de mortalité
infantile supérieur à la moyenne dans
les tribus de la côte
oui
quand il n'y a pas de danger que la
pêche au rasoir est ouverte à toute la
population américaine
dane et sa famille se précipitent sur
les immenses plages situées en dehors
des territoires indiens
les gens sont capables de faire des
centaines de kilomètres uniquement pour
ramasser leurs 15 rasoir et ensuite
reprendre le volant pour rentrer du lait
convenu c'est une tradition qui court
depuis des centaines d'années et les
gens adorent ça et c'est parce qu'il ya
si peu de jours de pêche
il ya autant de gens qui rappliquent
les quotas de cette pêche sont donc très
stricte mais les pêcheurs inexpérimenté
peuvent passer des heures et des heures
sur le sable avant de débusquer le long
mollusques
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas qu'il ya
dans ce coin de croo coquillages et
quand je dis gros c'est comme ça les
gens n'y connaissent rien et se contente
de creuser là où il entre sur la plage
avec leur voiture comme ça ils n'ont pas
à conduire dans le sol et ne risque pas
de sable lors de ces pêche récréative
toutes les techniques sont permises même
les enfants ont le droit à leur quota à
une seule condition qu'ils mettent la
main à la tâche
[Musique]
m
lamarre est à son niveau le plus bas il
est 18 heures mais sur des kilomètres de
plages les retardataires labour encore
le sable
bientôt quelques lampes tempêtes vont
s'allumer pour un dernier coquillages
malgré les menaces d'empoisonnement sans
cesse rappelée par les autorités et des
réglementations de plus en plus strictes
il était lors de cette marée plus de
4000 pêcheurs tous prix de la folie du
rasoir
hu
[Musique]